[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اغلق الطالبان الباب الاخير في
وجه المراه الافغانيه فتحت حكم طالبان لا
يتوقف مسلسل انتزاع حقوق النساء في اخر
فصول القيود المفروضه عليهم حضرتك تعليم
الجامعي للفتيات بعد ان امر وزير التعليم
العالي في حكومه الطالبان باغلاق جميع
الجامعات الحكوميه والخاصه للطالبات حتى
اشعار اخر سلب حقوق المراه في افغانستان
تعد التعليم لحرمانها حتى من الترفيه فقرر
اغلاق الجامعات قرار اغلاق الجامعات ياتي
بعد سلسله اجراءات تعسفيه ضد المراه تتعلق
بقياد اللباس وحرمانها من دخول المتنزهات
وصالات الرياضه وايضا الملاهي
[موسيقى]
معنى من دبي نور الله سلامه
يا سيد نور اهلا بك يعني بدايه الى اين
تتجه طالبان بالمراه الافغانيه وافغانستان
بعد هذا القرار هل ستتحمل تابعات ام هو
تحدي
لا نتوقع من طالبان يقوم باي عمل انساني
خيري يدعو الى تطور وتنميه
الاخلاقيات اصلا يتدربت خلال 20 سنه على
دمار
من الحياه
وهذا الوزير نفسه الذي يمنع اليوم البنات
من حضور الجامعات قد تحدث قبل ايام في
وزارته لتقييم شهادات حركه الطالبان وقال
لي الوزاره عندكم
مطالبه هؤلاء باي شكل من الاشكال الذي فجر
اكثر الذي لقى اكثر الذي قتل اكثر الذي
دمر الوطن اكثر هذا له اداه اخرى وهذا يجب
ان يحصل عليها ويجب ان يكون شهاداته
معتمده ولا تحتاج الى تقييم اصلا تقييمه
هو تفجيره وانتحاره هو عدد الجرائمه التي
التقبت في حق الشعاب الافغاني فنحن ماذا
نتبقا هل هذا الوزير وهذه الجماعه وهل هذه
الحكومه ستاخذ افغانستان للمريخ والى
عطارد والى القمر لا هؤلاء ولا سيعودون
جاب فانستاني وانت كما هذه سياستها اصلا
افغانستان في مثل هذه السياسات الصيفيه
اتجاه المراه منع التعليم واتجاه الخدمات
العامه يعني
حتى لنا نستمع الى تبريد طالبان وردود
الفعل على قرار الحاجه الحركه ارجو ان
تبقى معي
طيب وزير التعليم حركه طالبان برر قرار من
الفتيات من دخول الجامعات الافغانيه ببيئه
التعليم والمناهج مشيرا الى ان الحكومه
ستعيد النظر في اغلاق الجامعات بعد تعديل
المناهج على حد قوله هذا القرار لك
طبعا لا تركيه واتخذ في الاسبوع الاخير من
الامتحانات النهائيه في الجامعه لقد
تمديدا واسعا في بريطانيا وامريكا حيث
اعتبرت واشنطن انه لا يمكن ان تكون طالبان
عضوا في المجتمع الدولي وهي لا تحترم حقوق
الفتيات
مره اخرى سيد نور الله سلاب المحلل
لاسياسي الافغاني يعني هذا الموقف
الامريكي او الغربي لكن لماذا الان طالبان
تتخذ هذا الموقف
لا تخرج تذهب الى المدرسه لا تذهب الى
المدرسه
تمنع من السوق تمنع من الحدائق يعني الناس
متفرغون تمام
90% من من النفس الحركه يقولون هذه
السياسات الفارغه ما لها اي اثر ايجابي
على حركه الطالبان ولا لها اي اثر مستقبلي
ان تبقى هذه الحركه في الحكم لان هذه
تستدعي ان يكون هناك تغييرات جذريه في وسط
الحركه الان الحركه منقسمه الى اهل القدس
يعني يريرون الشعب الافغاني ال- ال-
الليونه في التعامل ويريدون ان تكون هناك
مؤسسات الدوله التعامل وهم يحكمون بين
الان انت الحاكم الفعلي لهذا الوطن ما
عندك شغله غير المراه ما عندك شغل غير انت
الناس من التعليم يا اخي او جزء
انت يجب ان
تدعو الى كل الاشياء التي تقوي حكومتك
وتلقيها فتره اطول في الحكم فكان المفروض
على هؤلاء ان يقول اللبغان يلا كلكم
المدارس الان الامن والبد المستخدم
لهذا القرار
يعقبه ضغط على حكومه الطالبه لتغيير
قرارها ام لا ما تعتقد ذلك
هم الذين
جلسوا اكثر
تفوضونا مع هذه الحركه بماذا كانت هناك
جمهوريه وكان هناك نظام كان هناك الدستور
وكل هذه المؤسسات التي قامت بها افغانستان
خلال 20 سنه جاءت بدعم بريطانيا وامريكيين
لماذا جاوب الانقلاب على هذه المؤسسه
الحكوميه الديمقراطيه ولماذا همم الغوا
الحكومه المنتخب ايا كان المبرر الان
هؤلاء يتمسرون وياتونا الى طالبان
ويننجدون ويضغطون على طالبان يضغطون اصلا
معهم في الدوام كل هذه الفتره انا كافاني
عادي لا اجلس معهم 18 دقيقه لمناقشه في
هذه الامور الحساسه وامريكا بعظمتها
والكبريائها سنه ونصف تناقش هذه المواد في
الدوحه الان تقولوا لماذا تمنعون المراه
هم كانوا يدكون ان هذه الحركه ما عندها
شغله هي ست شوقي سوره الاسلام سوفى سوره
العمل الاسلاميه فتجاوي سوره الانفال سوف
تشوي سوره
هذه الاداره الحاكمه التي الان ما عندها
شغله غير انها تتوب حول المراه
سلاب المحل الافغاني شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
من الملف الافغانيه الى اوكرانيا في
اوكرانيا هي ضغط دائره المواجهه بين بوتين
وازيلنسكي الرجلان وقف على اكثر جبهتين
محتزماتين في الحرب الرئيس الروسي قام
بزياره النادره هي الاولى له منذ ثلاث
سنوات الى بيلاروسيا التي تثير قلقا
عالميا كبيرا في حال دخولها على خط
المواجهه بينما فاجا الرئيس الاوكراني
جنوده على اكثر الجبهات اشتعالا وهي ضخمه
زيارتان تحملان ربما رمزيه لكل طرف من حيث
الرسائل التحذيريه التي تندر بان الفتره
القادمه مفتوحه على مزيد من التصعيد سينما
بعدها تهديدات بوتن اليوم باستخمالي
باستخدامه اعمال تكتكيه جديده في اوكرانيا
قد تكون بلا روسيا هي المنطلق ما هو
التكتيك الجديد لا نعلم لكن عموما سنعرف
غدا اكثر عن خطط روسيا العسكريه للعام
المقبل التي اعلنها بوتين في اجتماع مع
كبار القاده العسكريين وذلك توقف لك
[موسيقى]
الوضع صعب جدا بهذه الكلمات وصفا بوتين
على الوضع في المناطق الاربعه التي ضمتها
موسكو مؤخرا كلماتهم قليله لكنها تحمل
الكثير من الرسائل في ثناياها موسكو لا
تبدو راضيه على تطورات تطورات الميدانيه
رغم اعلانها ضم جمهوريات دونيس لوغانس
الشعبيهتين وكذلك من طاقتي زبوجيا وخيرسون
التي سحبت منها اخيرا
كما ان رسالتها بوتين حملت ايضا تلميحا
الى استمرار التهديد الاخراني على هذه
المناطق من خلال دعوته الاجهزه
الاستخباراتيه الى التركيز اكثر من اجل
حمايه السكان هذه المناطق واصفا اياهم
بالمواطنين الروس
فيسبوكيا صعب للغايه الناس يعلقون الامال
عليكم ومن واجبنا حمايتهم وضمان سلامتهم
واحترام حقوقهم من جانبها سنواصلوا تعزيز
قواتنا في تلك المناطق بالمعدات العسكريه
من جديد حول امكانيه دخول الناس في الحرب
الاوكرانيه زيتون رعبا وخوفا غربيا حول
امكانيه دخول طرف ثالث دخوله الى غماره
هذه الحرب وهذه المره في مواجهه اوكرانيا
الولايات المتحده الدعم الاول لاوكرانيا
اعربت عن قلقها بعد هذه الزياره حيث اوضحت
السكرتيره الصحفيه للبيت الابيض كان نجم
كير ان واشنطن لطالما شعره بالقلق من دور
بيلاروسيا في الحرب ويتردد الحديث منذ
اشهر حول امكانيه مشاركه بيلاروسيا بشكل
مباشر في الحرب في اوكرانيا الى جانب
روسيا غير ان الموضوع ظل مجرد تكه هناك
حتى الان على الاخر
شوماكو بادوبلوماسيه السابقه اهلا بك سيد
يعني الرساله التي كان يريد ايصالها بوتين
الى اوكرانيا كيف تقراها وكيف تفسرها
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته هو تحيه
طيبه من اوكرانيا بصراحه البيانات
وتصريحات السيد بوتين سوريه بصراحه احلى
خاصه نحاول الوضع صعبها للسكان في مناطق
المحتله التي روسيا انضمت الى اليها يعني
خاصه في مدينه خرسون روسيا كل يوم بشكل
تقريبا ولكن
هو كمان في جنوب بكره يعني نحن الان نتمنى
لا يوجد اي تقدم من الروس في منطقه روسيا
تاريخ ده حتى المساعده مين روسيا البيضاء
يعني
كيف ستتغير موازين القوه بالتالي
بصفه عامه خبراء هنا في اوكرانيا يقولون
موازنه القوه
الجيش الروسي هو غير الضخم وموعدات عسكريه
روسيا البيضاء
غير
المتطاوره جدا
اليوم ايضا يتم الحديث عن تكتيك جديد روسي
لخوض هذه الحرب العديد من القاده الروس
كانوا لا يوافقون هذا توجا بخسارتهم
لخرسون لكن اليوم هل اوكرانيا مستعده لهذا
التكتيل التكتيك الجديد هل تقراه تعريف
عنه الشيء
بصراحه نحن لا نعرف اي تكتيك جديد روسيا
سوف تمارس اعلى اوكرانيا ولكن نحن
روسيا تستخدم جنودها مثل
محمود ممكن يدور حديث حول افتتاح جبهه
اخرى
على حدود اوكرانيه وروسيا بيضاء بصفه عامه
بيلر يعني هي كمان حنيفا روسي
مين بتاعه حار نار زعوطت كبير من البخار
معاداته عسكريه حتى بيلاروسيا هي على
الجارحه الروس في مستشفياتها لكن هل ذلك
تعتقد انه سيسرع في دخول الغرب اكثر الى
هذه الحرب هل ستقف الولايات المتحده
بريطانيا دول الغربيه موقفا اكثر صلابه
وشده تجاه روسيا
بصراحه نحن نسمعه في بعده
حاول تقديم اكثر من صعده
عسكريه
كمان نحن نسمعه تصريحات من سلطه اوكرانيات
الجيش اوكراني في حاله التاهيل
الهجوم من روسيا البيضاء
هناك عدد
من الجيش الروسي وروسيا شامل
شكرا جزيلا للسيد فلوديميرا شوماكو
بادوبلوماسيه سابق كنت معنا من
[موسيقى]
على واقع تصيد الروسي في اوكرانيا و غياب
اي بوادر على مفاوضات وشيكا حضر الرئيس
الالماني فرانكشتاينر نظيره الصيني في
اتصال هاتفي على استخدام نفوذه لدى روسيا
ورئيسها بلادي مربوط لوقف الحرب وانسحاب
القوات الروسيه
[موسيقى]
لدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه
بسبب اضرابات بريطانيا تحذيراتهم من فوضى
مطارات اوروبا
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله هكذا البيت الابيض جنود الموقف
الراهن بشان الاتفاق النوويه مع ايران
وقال مناسب للاتصالات بالبيت الابيض جون
كيربي للعربيه لانه لا تقدم حاليا في
احياء الاتفاق النوويه مع ايران ولا
توقعات بتقدم القريب واكد كربي ان عوده
العوده للاتفاق النووي ليس محطه تركيز من
واشنطن في الوقت الراهن واشار الى ان
واشنطن تتفق مع الاتحاد الاوروبي في ادانت
ايران بسبب قمع المحتجين
[موسيقى]
مساله هو احياء الاتفاق النووي كانت على
راس مباحثات جمعت مسؤول لها الشؤون
الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي جزء
بوريل ووزير الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين امير
عبد الله يان على هامش في قمه بغداد في
الاردن بوريل دعا طهران الى ابقائه قنوات
الاتصال المتعلقه باعاده احياء الاتفاق
النووي مفتوحه بينما رد عبد الله بان على
بقيه الاطراف اتخاذ القرار السياسي اللازم
لانقاذ الاتفاق
ايران
اكدت على استعداد ايران لاستئناف
المحادثات بشان ملفها النووي والوصول الى
الخطوات النهائيه لابرام الاتفاق النووي
مع مراعاه الخطوط الحمراء والنصوص المقدمه
من قبلنا وان تتعامل الدول الاخرى بواقعيه
اكثر
[موسيقى]
السلام الاستقرار الامن عناوين رئيسيه
ثلاثه تصدرت قمه بغداد للتعاون وشراكه في
دورتها الثانيه المنعقده في البحر الميت
في الاردن قادت الدول العربيه استعرضوا
انعكاسات الازمات الاقليميه والدوليه على
العراق والمنطقه مؤكدين على ان تجاوزها
يستوجب تعاونا اقليميه شاملا في البيان
الختامي للمؤتمر اكد المشاركون ان نجاح
هذا التعاونيه تطلب مبادئ حسن الجوار وعدم
التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه او استغلال اي
دوله
لشان هجمات على دوله اخرى
ان العراق متمسكن ببناء علاقات تعاون
وثيقه ومتوازنه مع كل الشركاء الاقليميين
والدوليين
وينها بنفسه عن اصطفافات المحاور واجواء
التصعيد
وينشد سياسه التهدئه وخفض التوترات وفي
ذات الوقت يرفض التدخل بشؤون الداخليه
ومس سيادته او الاعتداء على اراضيه ولا
يمكن اعتماد مبدا القوه في في مساعي حل
الخلاف او الاختلاف ولا نسمحوا باستخدام
هذا المبدا ضد العراق
بنفس الوقت لا نقبل ان ينطلق اي وتهديد من
العراق ضد اي دوله من دول الجوار او
المنطقه
التدخلات والاملاءات الخارجيه التي تريد
فرض هيمنتها على دول المنطقه مؤكدا ان
فرنسا تريد العمل بجد لتحقيق السلامه
بكل صدق وامانه مع كل واحد منكم لكي لا
تكون هناك اصوات خارجيه تفرضها ولكي لا
يكون هناك نموذج من الخارج او دروس تعطى
من اي جهه بل نريد العمل بجد لتحقيق
السلام واستقرار هذه المنطقه من العالم
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان اكد ايضا خلال كلمته في مؤتمر بغداد
2 وقوف السعوديه جنبا الى جنب مع العراق
لصوم الاستقراره وحدث سيادته ودعم جهودي
التنمويه في والنهوض به لمرحله جديده تقدم
المصلحه الوطنيه على اي اعتبارات اخرى
مع العراق
جديده تقدموا مصلحه الوطنيه فيها على اي
اعتبارات اخرى اصحاب الجلاله والمعاني من
اجتماعنا اليوم يؤكدونا رغبه المشتركه
والصادقه لدولنا الاستمرار وتيره التعاون
والدعم لجمهوريه العراق
وترجمتها الى اشتراكات فعليه تحقق نتائج
العراق الاقتصاديه والتنمويه
ورخاء جيرانها والمنطقه يا جماعه
[موسيقى]
من نقص في امدادات الغزل الطبيعيه الى
اوروبا واتفاقهم ازمه الطاقه فيها بعد
تواصل الاتحاد الاوروبي امس الى وضعي سقفا
لاسعار الغاز فقال البنك عندنا وضع سقف
لسعر الغاز بدون ربطه بالطلب يهدده بعجز
في امدادات الغاز في اوروبا وقد يجبر
الحكومات على تقنين استهلاك الغاز في اسوا
السيناريوهات
الزميل لا ناصر الطيبي يشرح لنا قرار
الاتحاد الاوروبي بوضع سقف لسعر الغاز
وشروط تطبيقه
اذن مشاهدينا بعد اسابيع من النقاشات
الصعبه توصلت دول الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
اتفاق حول تحديد سقف لسعر الغاز وقد
اعترضت المجر على الاتفاق بينما تحفظت
هولندا والنمسا
نتحدث الان عن السقف السعر في الاتحاد
الاوروبي الذي تم وضعه بعد الكثير من
المفاوضات عند مستوى ال 180 يورو للميجا
وات ساعه طبعا هذا يبدا تطبيق السقف
السعري في الخامس عشر من فبراير المقبل
عندما نتحدث عن هذا السعر نتحدث عن عقود
الشهر المقبل التي يتم تداولها في البورصه
الهولنديه تي تي اف وهي اكبر بورصه لتداول
عقود الغاز في الاتحاد الاوروبي طبعا يتم
تفعيل هذا السقف السعري في
مرتين اساسيين لتفعيله الشرط الاول انه
السعر لعقود الشهر المقبل في البورصه
الهولنديه تي تي اف تتجاوز ال 180 يورو
للميجا وات ساعه لمده ثلاثه ايام على
التوالي هذا الشرط الاول اما الشرط الثاني
فهو ان ايضا يكون السعر همم العقود الشهر
المقبل بعد ان تتجاوز لمده ثلاثه ايام ال
180 همم يورو يجب ان تكون اعلى من السعر
العالمي للغاز المسال ب 35 يورو للميجا
وات ساعه وسيتم اختيار مؤشر قياس همم
ليكون هو الدليل لسعر اسعار الغاز المسال
عالميا مع العلم بانه لا يوجد هناك سعر
موحد للغاز المسال في العالم اذا هذا
بالنسبه
للسقف السعر همم مع صار بانه هذا السقف
فقط يفعل على التداولات في البورصه لا
يفعل على التداولات اوفر ذا كاونتر وليس
له علاقه بعقود توريد الغاز طويله الاجل
من خارج الاتحاد الاوروبي
ازمه اخرى تعصفه في اوروبا بعيدا عن الغاز
انها الاضطرابات وتداعياتها فحمى
الاضرابات لا تزال تجتاح مختلف ربوع
بريطانيا والدور جاء ايضا على دول اوروبيه
اخرى اخر المنظمين للحمله عمال الخدمه
العامه والتجاريه الذين يخوضون اضرابهم
الاول يوم الجمعه المقبل ويستمر
لثلاثه ايام على ان يخوضوا اضرابا ثانيا
نهايه السنه ما يمضي بقوضه في حركه
الرحلات الجويه على اعتبار انا موظفي
مراقبه منافذ الحدود مع نيون ايضا
بالاضراره هذا هو ستؤدي هذه الاضرابات الى
تاثر الحركه في العديد من المطارات في
البلاد في توقيت حساسه من السنه التزامنا
مع اعياد الميلاد
هيئه الطيران المدني في بريطانيا تحذيرا
للمسافرين بشان احتماليه التاخير في ايام
الاضراب وسبق عند ذكر صحيفه تايمز ان
شركات الطيران ربما تخطط اعداد المسافرين
بنسبه 30 بالمئه في حال شهدت المطرات
ازدحاما لا طاقه لها به
من بين اكثر الاضرابات اثاره للجدل وجذبا
للاهتمام اضراب عمال التمريض في مناطق
مختلفه او الممرضين في مناطق مختلفه في
بريطانيا مطالبينا برفع الاجور فرق
التمرين خاضت اضرابا تاليا يمتد لاربع 24
ساعه رغم مطالب الحكومه بالتراجع عن هذا
الاضراب لما في ذلك من تعريض لحياه الناس
او حياه المرضى للخطر تحديدا يبدا بان
الطرفين
او لا سيران في اتجاه الوصول الى ارضيه
للتفاهم ما يعني بان التصعيد قد يتواصل
وفي احدث رد لها قالت الحكومه البريطانيه
انها لن تقدم المزيد من الاموال لاطقم
التمريض والاسعافات من اجل انهاء
الاضطرابات من جهته قال رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني سوناك ان الوقت لا يسمح
بمناقشات مساله الاجور واشارك اكثر من
100,000 ممرض وممرضه من انجلترا وويلز
ايرلندا الشماليه في هذه الاضطرابات
[موسيقى]
معنا من لندن مراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو
مصطفى اهلا بك قبل ان اسالك عن الممرضين
واضرابهم والى اين وصل بودي ان يتسائل عن
المطارات هل هناك اجراءات قد تتخذها
الحكومه البريطانيه لمواجهه هذه الاضرابات
خاصه في هذه الفتره الحساسه من السنه
وتوقيت اعياد الميلاد وراس السنه
ما سمعناه وحتى الان من من طرف الحكومه
وان احبرت المسافرين خلال هذه الفتره فتره
4 ايام على مرتين ابتداءا من يوم الجمعه
لمده اربعه ايام ومن ثم يعودون لاربعه
ايام اخرى ضباط حرس الحدود سيقضون هذا
الادراك يعني بسبب المطالبه برفع الاجور
وايضا مواجهه تكلفه المعيشه التي شهيدناها
في في الاشهر او خاصه في هذا العام همم
الحليب بسبب الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
بالاضافه الى نسبه التضخم التي سجلت في
هذا البلد لاعلى المستويات منذ اربعه عقود
وبالتالي ليست هناك حتى هذه اللحظه اي
بوادر بان هذا هذه الاضرابات خاصه فيما
يتعلق بحرس الحدود انهم همم يعني سيعدنون
عنها هناك سته سته مطارات
سيتم الاستعانه من موظفين المدنيين وايضا
همم عناصر من الجيش البريطاني للعمل همم
تشغيل الخطوط الاماميه لهذه الاماكن وايضا
هي قطاعات حيويه جدا ولكن الكل ان ينتظر
مائده سيتم يعني تنفيذ هذا الاضراب وهو
اضراب ضخم كما اا يعني كما كما كما نعرف
بالاضافه الى ايضا الاضرابات الاخرى وكما
ذكرت همم
اطقم التمريض وهو اكبر اضراب تشهده البلاد
في قطاع خدمات
الوطنيه بالاضافه الى اطقم الاسعاف يعني
القطاعين سواء التمريض او حتى في المطارات
وحرس الحدود الحكومه البريطانيه هل اتخذت
قرارها بانها لن تدفع المزيد من الاموال
او حتى الدخول في مفاوضات معهم هل اغلق
هذا الباب
في اخر تعليق من الحكومه ومن ريشه هناك
الذي يعني مثلا امام لجنه برلمانيه لاول
مره منذ ان حضي
بمنصب رئيس الوزراء قال بان يحترم هذا
القطار قطاع الصحه ولكن كانت هناك لجنه هي
التي حددت رفع الاجور بنسبه تقريبا 5%
بينما تطالب النقابه بما يقارب بين 17 في
المئه ويجيب التذكير بانها نسبه التضخم
يعني اقل من 11% وبالتالي تقول الحكومه ان
ليس لديها اموال تسعه مليارات جنيه هذه
الاجور وهذا سيؤدي الى مزيد من التدخل
بالتالي كانت احدى الاولويات ليه ريشه
هناك عندما تسلم مقاليد السلطه وهو
السيطره على التضخم ولا يريد ان اا تزيد
هذه النسبه التي ستؤثر على حياه الناس
بشكل عام
همم شكرا جزيلا لمراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو
كنت معنا من لندن
[موسيقى]
ومن ازمه الغاز مرورا بالاضرابات الى خطرا
يهدد اوروبا انها انفلونزا الطيور التي
عادت في قوه حيث قالتها سلطات الصحيه
الاوروبيه ان اوروبا استحوذت على اكبر
انتشارا انفلونزا الطيور في القاره العام
الماضي فيما يدرس الخبراء جدول لقاحات
وقالت هيئه الاوروبيه لسلامه الاغذيه
والمركز الاوروبي للوقايه من الامراض
ومكافحتها انه بين اكتوبر العام الماضي
وستمر الماضي تم اكتشاف حوالي 2500 حاله
تفشي لانفلونزا الطيور في مزارع 37 دوله
اوروبيه في حين ذبح حوالي 50 مليون طائر
في المزارع المتضرره
[موسيقى]
خبط فصائل فلسطينيه اضرابا عامه في الضفه
الغربيه تمديدا بوفاه السجين الفلسطينيين
ناصر ابو حميد الذي كان مصابا بسرطان
الرئه ودعت حركه فتح الى مواصله الاضرابات
في مدن الضفه الغربيه ردا على ما وصفته
بالجرائم المرتكبه بحق الاسرى الفلسطينيين
واتهم رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني
اسرائيل بالاهمال الطبي المتعمد
اضراب شامل شل مختلف في مناحي الحياه في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه رافقته مسيره احتجاج
على احتجاز اسرائيل جثمان الاسير ناصر ابو
حميد الذي قضى داخل السجون الاسرائيليه
بعد معاناته مع مرض السرطان اهمال الطبي
هو تلكؤ في التشخيص وهذا بالمناسبه يحدث
مع كل الاسره ثم بعد ذلك اجريت له عمليه
جراحيه
وتعرض لخطا طبي لدخول طبيب يعني غير مختص
في العمليه يعني كانت تدخله
ان دخل ناصر في حاله غيبوبه اللي حوالي
اسبوعين نتيجه ايضا همم اهمال طبي
ناصر البالغ من العمر 50 عاما ام ضمنها 30
سنه في السجون الاسرائيليه اخرها منذ
العام 2002 اضافه الى اشقاء اربعه يقطون
احكاما مؤبده اسرائيل لم تستجب للمطالب
الفلسطينيه والعربيه والدوليه من اجل
تسليم جثمانه الى عائلته
كل ما نريده ان نشجع ناصر كما يليق وكما
يجب وان ندفنه الى جانب اخي الشهيد عبد
المنعم هذا قوه مطلبنا
نحن اتصلنا مع اشقاء عرب مؤثرين سواء كان
على الجانب الاسرائيلي وتصلنا ايضا
بالجهات الامريكيه وبالاداره الامريكيه
للتدخل مباشره لتسليم جثمانه لا يعقل
اطلاقا شخص تعرض الى الاهمال الطبي هناك
اربع اخوان له اسره ما زالوا في سجون
الاحتلال يعني اقل ما يمكن بالحد الادنى
من التكريم ان يسلم الى والدته والى اخوته
اكثر من 4000
معتقلون في السجون الاسرائيليه بينهما
العشرات يعانون من امراض مزمنه قد يواجهون
نفس المصير الذي لقيه ناصر
اسيرا فلسطيني
وما تزال اسرائيل
اضيف اليه من اليوم ناصر ابو حميد لتبقى
المطالبات الفلسطينيه بتحرير جثامين
الاسرى متواصله
على مختلف المستويات
من امام مخيم الامعري قرب رام الله خالد
القاسم العربيه
لدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه
المنتخب المغربي فرحه العوده الى الوطن
بعد دخول التاريخ في مونديال خطا
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله اتهم 100 موظف سابق في شركه
تويتر بارتكاب انتهاكات قانونيه مختلفه
بعد استحواذ الى الماسك عليها ويتهم هؤلاء
الموظفين تويتر بالتمييز على اساس الجنس
لاستهداف النساء في حمله التسريح التي
شملت موظفي المؤسسه كما وجه الثالث في
اجبار العمال ذوي الاعاقه على ترك العمل
بعد رد سماح لهم بالعمل عن بعد هذا وطلب
هؤلاء الموظفين ايضا بادانه التويتر
للقيام بطرد عمال بسبب انتقادهم الشركه
ومحاولتهم تنظيم الضباب عن العمل
[موسيقى]
يشرف العام 2022 علمي نهايه ستكون لنا
وقفه يوميه في نهايه اخبار الساعه مع ابرز
احداث هذه السنه وبدايه والبدايه باحداث
شهر يناير
[تصفيق]
اعلن لكم
استقالتي من منصب رئيس الوزراء
الوطن العزيز
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طول عمرك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نهايه النشره تفكيرهم بابرز العلم
[موسيقى]
بعدين انتزاعي كل حقوقهن حرمان المراه
الافغانيه من التعليم الجامعي طالبان تبرر
وامريكا تهدد
زياره ثاني تحميلها لنا رسائل لتصعيد وشيك
وروسيا تحضر تكتيكا جديدا في اوكرانيا
قمع الاحتجاجات في ايران يغير اولويات
الغربي مع طهران ويجمد الرغبه في احياء
الاتفاق النووي
انفلونزا الطيور تعود بقوه سلطات الصحيه
الاوروبيه ترصد انتشاره انتشارا هو الاكبر
في تاريخ الخطا
شكرا لكم هل يطيب المتابعه اخاكم على راس
الساعه دمتم في رعايه الله وحفظه في امان
الكريم
[موسيقى]